il est ici pris beaucoup en tout temps
mais depuis que la terre a tremblé il y
a dix ans la ferveur des croyants est
encore plus intense
le 12 janvier il remercie dieu de les
avoir épargnés jour-là et prie pour que
cessent les violences
l'animal et puis ma peau me battre avec
itunes et app t on qu on fait du
commerce mène batasuna one dès midi
dernier aidera vraiment passé oui moi
j'ai le phare de ré si les haïtiens
reste marqué c'est que leur quotidien
est encore plus difficile qu'avant ils
ont l'impression que leur gouvernement
n'a rien fait pour les aider à se
relever des ans plus tard on allait
[Musique]
le président joël moïse déposent une
gerbe de fleurs au mémorial érigé là où
des milliers de victimes du séisme sont
enterrés la cérémonie se déroule sous
haute surveillance
le public n'y a pas accès mais une
trentaine de manifestants font irruption
en militant du groupe
je laisse mes propres dénonce un état
qui n'a jamais selon respecter les morts
du séisme
mais les survivants puissions mais c'est
bien fait pour le bo accepté d'autant
qu'il n'est pas en état
on est avec les la colère des haïtiens a
explosé glee à 18 mois avec le scandale
de petrocaribe et 10 milliards de
dollars détournés un scandale de trop
pour une population qui peine à se
nourrir
nous avons demandé au président d'haïti
ce qu'il fait pour mettre fin aux
violences qui secoue son pays depuis
nous sommes arrivés au carrefour où nous
devons passer à l'affrontement ou ou à
l'entente le président admet que la
corruption est le principal problème de
son pays
que fait-il pour la combattre je suis en
train de libérer et à face au détail
capture les têtes actuels et passés
at-elle aux dégâts qu on peut le
président veut modifier la constitution
du pays et transformer les mentalités
égoïste qui entraîne corruption et
violences
il dit bousculez des intérêts puissants
et riches qui tentent à leur tour de le
faire tomber
je ne veux pas aller dans les poubelles
de l'histoire mais non je ne suis pas en
train de toucher des intérêts pour le
pour faire le bonheur de moi-même et de
mes amis je suis intérêts de tous et des
intérêts pour faire le bonheur du peuple
quand on lui demande s'il craint d'être
tué par ses adversaires le président
répond qu'il faut bien mourir un jour
mais qu'il n'a pas l'intention de
quitter trop tôt ni la présidence ni
cette vie sur terre
ici sophie langlois radio-canada port au
prince